hallo ihr lieben damals original
tiramisu rezept so gut bei euch ankam
zeige ich euch heute noch eine variante
des tiramisu und zwar machen leute
zitronen tiramisu aus zutaten die man
ganz einfach her bekommt ohne rohes ei
und ohne alkohol also auch für kinder
super und ich zeige euch hier
zuallererst zutaten
wir benötigen ganz klassischer weise
löffelbiskuits außerdem zum eintunken
bitter lemon den könnt ihr auch ersetzen
dazu sage ich euch später was außerdem
entweder bio zitrone oder bio limetten
für die creme benötigen wir mascarpone
magerquark creme fraiche oder schmand
außerdem puderzucker und sahne steif
wir starten jetzt zuallererst die
leckeren zitronencreme und ich verwende
hier ganz einfach schüssel und
schneebesen ich verwende ekstrand ich
meine küchenmaschine damit ihr auch mal
sehen dass es auch manchmal ohne geht
und man wie gar nicht immer braucht und
zuallererst gebe ich jetzt drei zutaten
hier links von mir in die schüssel
nämlich magath mascarpone und crème
fraiche
[Musik]
und die zutaten die könnt ihr
untereinander ganz einfach austauschen
wenn ihr mehr magerquark mögt dann tut
es gern rein und dann tauschte das ganz
einfach aus wichtig ist dass wir
ungefähr 1,4 kilogramm masse haben für
die menge die ich heute mache und als
nächstes gehe ich puderzucker rein
ihr könnt auch ganz normal ein kristall
zu kann ihm aber der löst sich besser
auf und deswegen nämlich am liebsten
puderzucker
[Musik]
nachdem wir jetzt erstmal die zutaten
gut miteinander verrührt haben geben wir
den abrieb der bio zitrone oder juni
metten reinig mit bio zitrone und zwar
zwei stück damit auch richtig viel
zitronengeschmack drin haben und geizt
auch wirklich nicht ihr werdet es mir
später danken im geschmack
und das riecht schon richtig lecker hier
nach zitrone und jetzt können wir das
auch noch mal unter dann gebe ich aber
noch ein bisschen zitronensaft rein
[Musik]
also hier nämlich nur den saft einer
halben zitrone ihr könnt natürlich
entscheidend wie zitrone ich ihr das
mögt ich mag es lieber so und gebe jetzt
nochmals alle steif da rein und dann ist
die creme auch schon fertig so ihr
lieben ihr habt gesehen die creme ist
schon fertig und war gar nicht schwer
total einfach liebe solche rezepte und
jetzt geben wir unsere löffelbiskuits in
unser unternehmen dazu hatte ich noch
was sagen
ich persönlich liebe bitter lemon könnte
das jeden tag trinken sollte man
natürlich nicht so viel zucker aber ihr
könnt das auch ersetzen falls ihr das
nicht möglich metten saft orangensaft
irgendeine zitronenlimonade was auch
immer ihr möchtet und ich tue das ganze
mit der zucker weiter nach unten ein und
mache dann den boden in einer
auflaufform damit fertig
[Musik]
und hier muss man einfach mal tetris
spielen damit auch die löffelbiskuits
richtig schön in den boden passten
wenn ihr das dann erledigt habt gebt ihr
die hälfte eurer zitronencreme drauf und
streicht die glatt
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die kleeblatt
verstrichen haben gehen wir einmal die
andere hälfte der löffelbiskuits darüber
und die andere hälfte der creme und dann
sind wir auch schon fast fertig
[Musik]
und hier noch ein kleiner tipp von mir
wäre das so richtig lecker sommerlich
mag der kann hier noch kokosraspeln in
die zwischenschichten hinzufügen leider
habe ich jemanden der familie der kein
kokos markt deswegen muss ich darauf
verzichten aber beim nächsten mal
verspreche ich mir dann mache ich
kokosraspeln rein super-kombination
jetzt doch die creme brauch und streicht
das schön glatt
[Musik]
und eigentlich ist unsere zitronen
tiramisu jetzt schon fast fertig aber
wir machen noch eine schöne dekoration
die zeige ich euch noch nach der kühl
zeit die kühlste ist wichtig damit das
ganze schön fest geht und wir uns dann
später richtig schöne stücke aus
schneiden können
ich würde sagen vier stunden auch wenn
ihr sagt manno muss ich so lange warten
macht vier stunden lang habt ihr richtig
schöne feste schnitte ansonsten jedoch
zwei stunden dann ist es nicht ganz so
fest auch nicht stimmt ihr könnt aber
auch gerne einen tag vorher zu bereiten
und dann über nacht kühlen lassen
das funktioniert auch so nach der
schulzeit ist in der zitrone tiramisu
fast fertig wie gesagt es fehlt noch die
deko und die mache ich jetzt anhand von
zitronenscheiben und minzblättern ich
zeig euch jetzt wie ich die
zitronenscheiben in szene setzte und sie
dann auf mein zitronen tiramisu lege
[Musik]
so meine lieben das ist das zitronen
rami so schmeckt unglaublich erfrischend
und total leicht falls es ganz nach
machen möchte dann schreibe ich euch
hier unten in der infobox wie immer die
genauen mengenangaben und die zutaten
macht euch einen screenshot geht
einkaufen und dann freue ich mich über
eure fotos mit dem hashtag in sketchen
auf instagram dürften nicht vergessen
diesem video im dörfchen nach oben zu
geben und ein feedback dazu lassen ich
freue mich wenn dem einen kanal
kostenlos abonniert dann verpasst ja
auch nichts mehr
und ihr könnt natürlich auch die glocke
aktivieren damit kommt die immer eine
benachrichtigung so bis zum nächsten mal
auch dieses kitchen tschüss
[Musik]